could be the beginning of the end of the
covid pandemic
and tonight vials of vaccines for kobit
19
are in nevada thank you for joining us
at 11 i'm brian loftis
now the first doses were administered
today but it is just the beginning
8 news now reporter orco mana joining us
live from umc with details on the
distribution timeline
orco
well brian today hundreds of frontline
healthcare workers here
at umc were the first people in nevada
to get the coven 19 vaccine
this is a major turning point in our
state's efforts to finally end
this global pandemic we really had tears
in our eyes as
the vaccine was arrived here a historic
day in nevada as a significant step is
made in the battle against the
coronavirus
umc becoming the first hospital in the
state to administer pfizer's coven 19
vaccine to about 200 of its front-line
health care workers monday
the very first to get it an icu nurse
who treats kovid 19 patients
and this is the first vial that's been
administered in the state of nevada
just over 1800 of these vials are part
of umc's first allocation of the vaccine
each vial containing about five doses
umc's ceo says they have a detailed
distribution plan to help our most
vulnerable
we'll be working very closely with the
nursing home community
and the health district to be able to
roll that out to make sure that we're
protecting the healthcare workers in
nursing homes
but also in patients in the nursing
homes and we'll also be looking at our
patients that are in umc as well
that'll we need to get through the
health care workers first the southern
nevada health district getting more than
12 thousand doses of the vaccine monday
morning it'll continue to come in phases
and once it becomes widely available
mass vaccination sites will be set up
the venues
will be much similar to the the covid
testing sites that we've seen
we might leverage the
resort properties that are have not
opened where they have a parking
structure
it might be local high schools
definitely community centers
and senior centers umc expects to
vaccinate close to 5 000 medical workers
over the next week
i see hope on the horizon and things
moving very quickly for our community
umc's ceo says the vaccine shipments are
coming relatively quickly into nevada
so he actually expects the general
public to start getting vaccinated by
late january or early february no later
than march
that's earlier than previously predicted
reporting live from umc tonight
orco mana 8 news now